five you're a conspiracy theorist 3 2 1
go all right here I go oh my God holy
[__] she just poured a bunch of water in
there wait she just poured a glass of
water on the dumplings to slide she
sweating she's washing it down that's
it's a
lubricant I think that's what she was
saying that you can't Guinness wouldn't
let her do that how many how do we stop
are you counting no cuz we know how
many's in the Box dad so we'll see how
many afterwards don't bother her it's
yeah it's like a whole it's like a fluid
situation I don't think you could even
identify look what she's doing dude
she's going to can you imagine if you
were on a date Dad don't bother her that
a good question no I
know I bet I don't think she eats like
that on a day what could be you go honey
the movie starts in a couple minutes
could you just finish could you just
finish up
oh thank you for um waiting for
me that's that's
beautiful h this is crazy how's the time
where are we at on the time backstage
guys it's four minutes minutes four
minutes left oh wow yeah that was only
one minute she going to destroy 30
thought you thought that you could keep
up with her soon put the first one in
her mouth I was like no I finish the
whole box so she's at 30 in a minute a
box is 30 yeah yeah okay she's at 30 in
a minute I knew she's a fierce
competitor she going to you're
amazing she knows she not an affirmative
so what's your sign
sh it's a funny date this would be an
amazing date I eat seven howwi we I
think I'm out now though really I'm you
got to eat them
properly oh my goodness her paste is
really impressive still this is good how
do you do this keep this paste though
for like 10 minutes she's a professional
she's a professional this is an athlete
this is going to be in the Olympics in
about 5 years this is amazing
this has got to be one of the weirdest
Sports ever imagine you're like starving
Africa a lot of guys like women Sudan or
Yemen I wonder if this is America she's
from Walnut you haven't had a meal in
like that's good oh tea time this is
time for stop we this is amazing is she
almost crushed that box this is the
second box second box when do she
swallow I think it goes to what he said
that's the question I wasn't how that's
inappropriate well I thought you were
being inappropriate excuse you should
have heard the first half of this
podcast
wow man I like that she's very um she
doesn't talk with a mouthful you know
she's very why is this on America's Got
Talent yeah you should be on America's
Got Talent would you ever come on sh Dad
yeah yes she says you can get her on I
mean you're a judge right I get her on
I'm judging you right now this is golden
but oh no what do you think think she
that's 60 I think that's she just it's
60 60 and we still have 2 minutes left
honestly she shouldn't even have to open
those boxes but that's am yeah it should
have already been opened I blew it for
you but she'll break this record this is
an amazing record oh oh oh I
thought I thought you was giving back
how many are left in your box cuz you
might need it oh oh for real one two
three four five six seven 8 did we [__]
up I think we did I think you did
10 left there's 10 in this oh my
goodness how are we have you have you
ever had a Togo
bag don't make her laugh there but that
means she ate a 100 oh my God she's
already eaten 100 is that what that
means no this one will be this this
third box will be 90 90 and okay five
minutes she has five minutes left how
many minutes she has 1 minute 1 minute
and 10 seconds left 1 minute and 10
seconds she's only been eating for 4
minutes this is a
amazing she man she comp imagine how
well she can do if my dad wasn't next to
her oh what she doing uh digestion yoga
what happened she was twisting her hips
GL Twisted that way I don't know how
she's making room that time she Twisted
towards you oh my God I don't know she's
jumping now to make space holy smokes
man oh my God this is
crazy she like a wood chipper of
dumplings jumping died Coke yeah you
don't want to this is amazing it is
amazing so does she have diarrhea or is
it solid we talked about it does
sometimes she yeah cuz the body can't
possibly digest all that properly I
don't know what she's going to do but I
don't want to hang around for that end
result 20 seconds 20 seconds seconds let
us know when so we didn't [__] it up
probably no good no yo 20 you got the
[__] am I watching
you 9 8 7 6
5 4 3 2 1 oh my gosh I'm going to count
those ones in is the ru is the rule
generally that you need to swall how do
you feel how many left how do you feel
talk to me stop Dad I'm sorry give her a
minute what are you thinking right now
what's going give mic near you one two 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 there's 10 in here so
there was 20 out of this box so how many
is that so she had so she had wait 80
move the mic near you no no so three
boxes is 90 yeah so she had 80 so she
had 80 80 dumplings 80 dumplings in five
minutes is that a record 80 Dum that has
to be a record she did 90 amazing are
you eating her dumplings yeah she oh
you're right I'm married I'm sorry